[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zu unserem zdf heute live
heute mit dem thema corona hotspots eben
deutschland regelchaos für reisende und
pendler ja das ist die frage und darüber
sprechen wir mit felix zimmermann aus
unserer rechts redaktion und deutschland
seit längerer zeit mit vielen fragen
rund um die korona pandemie befasst
vielen dank und schön dass du da bist
heute abend bei uns im studio felix
letzte woche wieder schienen die ansage
der politik noch relativ klar zu sein
meiden sie nach möglichkeit reisen ins
ausland machen sie urlaub zu hause
inzwischen hat man den eindruck dass es
nicht mehr ganz so klar denn auch
innerhalb von deutschland gibt es
durchaus problematische region sollte
man am besten ganz zu hause bleiben
ob das weiß ich nicht also klar das war
wirklich so die die anweisung von herrn
spahn quasi die empfehlung bitte nicht
ins ausland was natürlich implizierte
bei uns im inlands da sieht es besser
aus ob jetzt ein risikogebiet nach dem
anderen im pop sich als solches aber den
ratschlag da würde ich jetzt nicht geben
man sollte eben acht geben und natürlich
gucken kann man da überhaupt hinreisen
wo man hin reisen will also auf diese
fragen werden wird beziehungsweise auch
die einzelheiten dazu dann gleich noch
ein gehen natürlich auch nochmal an euch
der hinweis wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt gerne her damit
per e-mail zum beispiel ans zdf heute -
live at zdf de und um das vielleicht
auch für euch liebe user noch mal
deutlich zu machen es gibt also
innerhalb deutschland inzwischen mehrere
regionen die eben auch als problematisch
angesehen werden was das
infektionsgeschehen angeht teilweise
werden sie als risikogebiete bezeichnet
teilweise werden dafür andere begriffe
verwendet trotzdem ist es problematisch
und um welche region es sich dabei
handelt wollen wir gerade noch mal kurz
anhand einer grafik nachvollziehen
als risikogebiet wird eine region
bezeichnet in der die zahl von 50 corona
neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohner in
den letzten sieben tagen überschritten
wurde
diese kreise liegen derzeit über dem
grenzwert
remscheid und haben der landkreis vechta
und gleich vier stadtteile im zentrum
berlins mitte friedrichshain kreuzberg
neukölln und tempelhof schöneberg ja
also das sind einige gebiete auch
relativ verteilt über deutschland kann
man sagen was heißt das jetzt felix für
die betroffenen person vielleicht mal
zunächst für diejenigen die dort wohnen
welche beschränkungen ergeben sich jetzt
zunächst mal daraus dass man dort wohnt
ja also für die die dort wohnen
innerhalb des jeweiligen kreises ergeben
sie das wird keine beschränkung
aber dann stellt sich die frage wenn ich
davon aus dem singkreis verlassen will
wenn ich in einem anderen bundesland
urlaub machen will wenn ich vielleicht
pendeln will
da geben sich daneben probleme und das
große problem dabei ist dass alles
überall völlig unterschiedlich geregelt
ist
also es gibt überhaupt kein
einheitliches gesetz was das festlegt
oder eine einheitliche verordnung und
jedes bundesland wegen des föderalismus
regelt dass selbst das heißt man kann
gar nicht pauschal sagen was jetzt genau
passiert wenn ich irgendwo urlaub machen
will oder wenn ich irgendwo hin muss als
pendler zum beispiel kann man nicht
pauschal so bremen und niedersachsen
gibt es aktuell überhaupt keine
beschränkung
da gibt hat also jemand der in einem
krone hotspot ist nichts zu befürchten
da kann er ganz normal hin reisen urlaub
machen oder auch beruflich unterwegs
sein
ansonsten muss man eben schauen vor
allem ein punkt ist wichtig aber mir
grad in der übersicht gesehen
es gibt zum beispiel berlin da die
verschiedenen bezirke in berlin
und diese werte die orientieren sich
nach dem situationsbericht in das
robert-koch-institut jeden tag
veröffentlicht aber jetzt gibt es
bundesländer die stellen nicht so
kleinteilig auf einen bezirk ab sondern
fragen größer nach landkreisen zum
beispiel in mecklenburg vorpommern ist
es so die sie in berlin als ganzes
danach darf man also noch nach
mecklenburg vorpommern reisen soll in
berlin als ganzes die krone ins events
unter 50 ist schleswig holstein hingegen
guckt auch nach den bezirken
und da darf man dann wenn man in berlin
mitte wohnt aktuell nicht mehr in
schleswig-holstein urlaub machen
zumindest also es ist immer wichtig die
individuellen also zum beispiel wohnorte
aber eben auch bestimmungen eben genau
zu verfolgen
die gelten für den ort zum einen an dem
man wohnt aber auch eben für den ort wo
man hin möchte
was heißt das denn jetzt für leute die
dorthin wollen oder müssen die woanders
leben aber da hin zum beispiel reisen
wollen oder eben auch beruflich dort
gebraucht werden oder dorthin müssen
also was die es gibt bestimmte
bundesländer zum beispiel mecklenburg
vorpommern die haben ein einreiseverbot
aber dann gibt's dann ausnahmen wer
beruflich unterwegs ist das gilt
übrigens auch für personen aus dem
ausland also das gilt erstmal das verbot
dann gibt es aber ausnahmen bestimmungen
das heißt aktuell wer beruflich
irgendwohin muss zwingt und wohin muss
der kann das auch weiterhin tun
ansonsten wäre zum beispiel urlaub macht
er muss eben ganz genau gucken was gilt
hier es gibt teilweise beherbergungs
verbote und andere sagen man muss 14
tage in quarantäne und dann ist der
urlaub auch schon vorbei und noch was
ihr zurück also das dann keinen sinn der
aktuell anzureisen aus ein crooner
hotspot gebiet muss man natürlich auch
immer wieder dazu sagen
wie ist es wenn ich dann studieren würde
weil ich jetzt er das ist also jetzt ein
risikogebiet wie ist es dann mit den
kosten
ja also das ist natürlich auch alles
noch neuland dann wird es noch
wahrscheinlich zehn jahre lang
juristische auseinandersetzungen geben
mit reiseveranstaltern und so weiter
aber kann man als grundsatz sagen wenn
ich eine pauschalreise habe gilt bisher
immer die rechtsprechung wenn eine
reisewarnung vom auswärtigen amt
ausgesprochen ist haben natürlich
innerhalb deutschlands nicht aber wenn
ich eine reisewarnung habe dann gegen
außergewöhnliche umstände vor und ich
kann die stornieren und muss auch nicht
zahlen wenn wir das jetzt überträgt die
idee der reisewarnung die ja deswegen
stattfinden ins ausland weil da auch die
krone inzidenz über 50 liegt und
überträgt das ins inland
dann gilt könnte naheliegenderweise das
gleiche gelten also sind die bestehen
gute aussichten bei einer pauschalreise
das zurückzubekommen und sonst muss man
sich immer rechtlich fragen ist denn
eigentlich noch mein ziel was ich habe
vor ort möglich oder liegt eine
unmöglichkeit vorjahr wenn man jetzt
immer noch die beherbergung realität
tatsächlich möglich ist dann geht
vielleicht ansonsten ist
machen wir mal ein konkretes beispiel
eva befragt hier über facebook kann ich
aus berlin schöneberg nach baden
württemberg und bayern fahren für fünf
tage also hinfahren kann man die frage
ist was passiert dann also berlin
schöneberg wie mich jetzt mal einer
geografischen kenntnisse nicht ganz
trüben ist nicht mit nein also insofern
eigentlich noch kein risiko hoher und
wenn ich jetzt richtig im kopf weil
baden-württemberg die frage aber auch
nach stadtkreisen so deswegen wenn man
jetzt da im stadtkreis von berlin wohnt
wo das über 50 ist würde es würde das
nicht gehen ja dort gilt daneben das
beherbergungs verbot für hoteliers die
sich jeden tag fragen müssen verdammt
noch mal woher kommt denn eigentlich
jetzt hier der urlauber man nachschauen
in der liste ist es hier in einem
risikogebiet ja darf ich denn überhaupt
beherbergen oder muss ich den wieder
wegstecken das natürlich für die auch
eine sehr schwierige situation also wir
merken schon wir sind da jetzt gleich im
richtigen leben drin diese fragen sind
nicht rein theoretisch sondern da geben
sich ganz praktische fragestellungen
wir haben einige beispiele
zusammengetragen meine kollegen volker
dutschek ohne duda und henriette de
maizière mit einzelheiten dazu sie
machen die nacht zum tag auch an diesem
wochenende in berlin
dabei vergessen viele offenbar alles was
sie tagsüber beherzigen abstand halten
mundschutz tragen
über die situation gerade in der
hauptstadt macht sich auch der
gesundheitsminister öffentlich sorgen
ich kann nicht verstehen dass es in
dieser stadt restaurants gibt in die ich
reingehe der einzige mit maske bin und
wurde dann noch angeguckt wird als wärst
irgendwie vom anderen mond wenn du eine
maske trägt und ihr dann noch gesagt wir
brauchen sich hier nicht tragen
schleswig holstein und rheinland pfalz
ziehen jetzt neue seiten auf hier müssen
rückkehr aus inländischen risikogebieten
wie berlin in der regel zwei wochen in
quarantäne
ausnahmen gibt es nur wenn der
notwendige corona test nicht älter als
48 stunden ist der reisende weniger als
72 stunden im risikogebiet war und es
triftige reise gründe gibt wie
sorgerecht und medizinische behandlung
schwierige zeiten auch für hoteliers ii
matthias weber wagner aus mainz er muss
jetzt reisen dem schlimmsten fall
abweisen oder im benachbarten hessen
unterbringen
wir schicken den gast zum flughafen das
ist das nächste die nächste größere
einrichtung wo man auch abends noch
einen corona das machen kann wenn er hat
dann nicht wiederkommt wie eben
vielleicht irgend eines unserer
schwester urteils in frankfurt ein
portieren
der reichstag oder das brandenburger tor
viele sehenswürdigkeiten die in berlin
mitte und das ist jetzt risikogebiet der
zuständige senat wehrt sich dagegen dass
einzelne stadtteile zum risikogebiet
erklärt werden
berlin auch heute voll von touristen
viele wollten oder konnten nicht
umbuchen
das problem ist wenn man sich erstmal
die nato gebucht hat und kann die reise
nicht zurückgeben und ich sag mal
passieren kann überall waren uns auch
nicht mit den öffentlichen medien sehr
viel
und ja also versuchen es so gut wie geht
von von anderen menschen fernzuhalten
deutschland bleibt vorerst ein
flickenteppich in sachen inländische
risikogebiete denn die bundesländer
dürfen bei den quarantänevorschriften
eigene regeln festlegen
jetzt ist gerade schon das stichwort
flickenteppich gefallen das ist nicht so
ganz aus der luft gegriffen wir können
uns das auch gerne auf einer karte noch
mal anschauen zu empfehlen bei uns auf
zdf.de ist also auch noch einmal
abgebildet was für reisende aus
inländischen risikogebieten gilt und wie
wir das hier sehen ist das doch relativ
unterschiedlich da ist zum einen in
einigen bundesländern ein sogenanntes
beherbergungs verbot in kraft kommen wir
gleich noch zu dann haben wir hier aber
auch andere bundesländer da gelten
andere regeln ohne negative
testergebnisse 14-tägige quarantäne und
so weiter dann gibt es auch andere
bundesländer wie zum beispiel
niedersachsen oder nordrhein westfalen
da gibt es noch keine quarantäne und
natürlich auch kein beherbergungs verbot
was ist denn zu diesem verbot speziell
zu sagen felix bedeutet das dass ich da
überhaupt nicht irgendwie übernachten
darf oder wie ist das zu verstehen
also wenn du einen negativen aktuellen
corinna test in der tasche hast und
vorweisen da ist dann kannst du
übernachten und sonst nichts
und das ist eben auch wiederum etwas
unterschiedlich geregelt in den
einzelnen bundesländern
wie gesagt manche haben wir gerade eine
karte gesehen bei manchen ist es
zulässig auch ohne es gibt kein verbot
und bei manchen wiederum greifen sogar
noch strengere regeln quarantäne
das natürlich sagen der flickenteppich
wird ja oft kritisiert aber andererseits
hat der tourismus natürlich auch
vorteile die regionen die eben starke
vielleicht betroffen sind können etwa
eben auch andere maßnahmen verhängen
das ist einerseits nervig natürlich für
urlauber verbraucher hat aber auch
vorteile also angesichts zu einer karte
wenn man die jetzt sieht und sieht okay
da gibt es unterschiedliche maßnahmen
unterschiedliche färbungen eben je
nachdem was dort passiert kann man den
leuten ja eigentlich nur raten sich
wirklich genau zu informieren über das
ziel in das man oder den ort zudem
anreisen möchte bzw dann auch über die
art und weise wie ich dann behandelt
werde als rückkehrer in meinen heimatort
gut wenn wir jetzt schauen auf die hotel
und gaststättenbranche die ist von der
pandemie nämlich ganz besonders
betroffen
auch von dieser problematik der
unterschiedlichen regionen und des
unterschiedlichen verfahrens sozusagen
mit den reisenden
da gibt es kritik durchaus wir haben
gerade die vorteile gehört aber es gibt
auch kritik an diesen föderalen
nebeneinander unter anderem von ingrid h
sie ist hauptgeschäftsführerin des hotel
und gaststättenverbandes dehoga wir
haben mal was sie zu sagen hat es ist
eigentlich unglaublich dass wir hier 16
unterschiedliche regelungs werke haben
manche nehmen bezug auf die vom ak ii
ausgewiesenen risikogebieten
andere nehmen bezug auf
veröffentlichungen ihrer
landesregierungen in manchem bundesland
kann ich ein reißen mit einem negativ
tests in einem anderen bundesland
brauche ich dazu denn noch mal einen
test in dem jeweiligen bundesland also
zwei tests innerhalb von fünf tagen bei
allem respekt für den föderalisten bei
einem respekt ich hörte herbst für mich
als eine gewisse kritik aus respekt ja
aber vielleicht doch auch
schwierigkeiten bei der umsetzbarkeit
also dieses nebeneinander von regelungen
scheint ja in der tat relativ
unübersichtlich zu werden insbesondere
wenn man jetzt daran denkt dass ja bald
dann auch die kalte jahreszeit kommt die
ist jetzt eigentlich schon da das heißt
die zahlen könnten ja dann auch nochmal
steigen
also das ist dann doch relativ viele
regionen gibt die davon betroffen sind
die dann eigentlich risikogebiet wären
auch innerhalb von deutschland ist dann
dieses system überhaupt so praktikabel
des problems bisschen die informationen
also einerseits unterschiedliche
regelung ist schon mal eine große
herausforderung für die verbraucher aber
na ja man könnte ja mal auf die idee
kommen eine internetplattform eine
gesamt übergreifende zu machen wo man
ganz einfach die daten ein klicken kann
die man vor hat und dann sofort als
ergebnis bekommt ob man darf oder nicht
also hier herrscht nicht nur eine regel
so war dass man so oder so sehen kann
sondern es herrscht ein transparenz
problem dass eben die person so ein
bisschen alleine gelassen werden und
sorgen haben zum beispiel ist auch eine
ganz einfache geschichte wenn ich
überlege ich komme aus einem
risikogebiet sagen manche es reicht
schon wenn ich da eine minute quasi in
berlin mitte war
andere sagen wiederum 24 stunden oder 48
stunden muss man im risiko beat
risikogebiet gewesen sein
aber das sind alles so viele
unterschiedliche voraussetzen das ist
wirklich schwierig ist und eine große
herausforderung für den verbraucher
wir haben hier immer mal wieder auch
kommentare thorsten einwohner zum
beispiel über facebook einfach das
überfahren der ländergrenzen innerhalb
deutschlands für private zwecke
verbieten lkw
der rest bleibt in seinem bundesland
dass pendler feuchten ja da muss
natürlich auseinander gezogen corona
wichtige sache diese krankheit die
einzudämmen so gut es geht aber es geht
immer noch freiheitsrechte es geht nur
noch die berufsfreiheit
es gibt noch die freizügigkeit und da
muss dann schon wirklich jede regelung
auch diese verschiedenen grundrechte
abwägen so dass man sagen kann hier
niemand reißt mir damit auf jeden fall
corona eingedämmt wird das ist nicht
zulässig müssen die verschiedenen güter
in einem einklagen und ausklang gebracht
werden jetzt sind mehrfach auch schon
die tests angesprochen worden mit denen
kann man sich ja dann zumindest mahlzeit
je nachdem wie der test ausfällt
sozusagen erkaufen oder zumindest gut
machen
man muss nicht ganz so lange in
quarantäne wie kommt man an diese tests
wie erfahre ich beziehungsweise genau
also wie muss ich mich verhalten wenn
ich also eine reise fort oder sie schon
gemacht habe möchte einen test machen
wie gehe ich davor als verbraucher also
dann ist hielt den hausarzt zu
kontaktieren oder den ärztlichen
bereitschaftsdienst anzurufen und dann
kann man einen test machen
entweder kriegen wir ihn bezahlt wenn
der gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist wenn
man nur aus sicherheitsgründen einen
will um ihn zum beispiel im hotel
vorzulegen wird es nicht bezahlt was ich
gelesen habe so die kosten so bei 50 50
euro
und es dauert so zwischen 24 und 48
stunden bis man ein ergebnis hat gibt
aber auch meldungen wo das irgendwie
plötzlich tage gedauert hat eine frage
hat uns auch noch erreicht bin ich
krankenversichert wenn ich bewusst in
ein risikogebiet fahre
das ist auf jeden fall zu bejahen man
verliert nicht so einfach sein
seine krankenversicherungsschutz und wer
also nach berlin-mitte reist oder sonst
wurde ist weiterhin kein versichert
soviel kann man die leute auf jeden fall
beruhigt
ich versuche noch ein paar unserer user
mitzunehmen paul englert auf facebook
was passiert wenn ich auf der fahrt nach
italien durch tirol klammer auf
risikogebiet klar
dazu fahre aber nicht aussteige ja da
gibt es auch wiederum schaut man sich
leichter muss ich sie ja sagen die
unterschiedlichen regelungen habe ganz
viele bundesländer für sagen die meisten
haben als ausnahmeregelung wenn man bloß
durchgefahren ist ja so dass geld oder
geht es auch wieder darauf hinzuweisen
man muss leider den mühsamen weg gehen
auf die internetseiten zum beispiel dass
sie bei den gesundheitsministeriums zu
gehen sich die korona verordnung dadurch
zu lesen beziehungsweise es gibt oft
ganz einfache formen davon erklärungen
also soweit sie die behörden schon dass
sie den bürgern das ein bisschen näher
bringen übersichtsliste dieses ganz
verständlich machen
aber auch dort gilt in der regel beim
bloßen durchfahren haben nichts zu
befürchten kann wieder einhalten
also wir versuchen verbrauchernahe zu
bleiben freak über youtube mit der frage
wenn man wegen eines arztbesuchs ins
ausland muss muss man dann in quarantäne
zb von bayern nach tschechien tschechien
risikogebiet dauer unter 48 stunden also
das ist die frage ist auch zu sagen
spielt der anlass für diese reise eine
rolle so manche bundesländer differieren
nach zeit aber wenn es der anlass aber
nicht nach dem anlass ja also ob man da
höchstens beruflich aber ob es jetzt
urlaub ist oder arztbesuch sonstige
private geschichten
wir spielen keine rolle dann vielleicht
auch mal abschließend gefragt wir haben
jetzt einige fragen schon besprochen
aber man könnte das merkt man jetzt
schon endlos quasi weiter diskutieren
weiß ich einfach auch unheimlich viele
detailfragen ergeben und weil das ganze
das muss man ja auch sagen irgendwie
alles noch ziemlich so im schwange ist
das kann ja dann auch im morgen oder
übermorgen schon wieder zu anderen
regelungen kommen also eine sehr
momentane sozusagen aufklärung die wir
hier nur betreiben können aber jetzt
noch einmal abschließend gefragt also
wenn man sich beschäftigt mit eben der
reise sei es jetzt privat oder
dienstlich veranlasst wo informiere ich
mich am besten wenn ich etwas vorhabe
wir sagen erst das problem wohne ich
überhaupt mit einem risikogebiet dass
man überhaupt irgendwo so bezeichnen
kann
da gehe ich also auf die internetseiten
des rk ii und schaue mir den täglichen
situationsbericht an
dann muss ich wenn ich pech habe auch
noch mal die letzten sieben tage
anschauen und gucke dann okay ist man
bezirk ein risikogebiet dass er erst die
erste wenn ein
kann man überall hinreisen und wenn ja
das zweite problem was ist mit dem
bundesland und dass sich reisen will
dann kleiner einschub ist das so
kleinteilig dass es berlin mitte als
eigenständige nord sieht oder größer
oder wird größer geschaut und dann
solche regelungen gelten dort wo ich hin
will geht um zwei herbergs verbot
kantine und so weiter internet zeichen
des ministeriums internetseiten der
verbraucherzentrale sind ja gute
anlaufstellen um in diesem schwierigen
dickicht dann dann doch irgendwie einen
weg zu finden hoffentlich schönen urlaub
ja und natürlich auf zdf.de versuchen
auch immer wieder zur aufklärung
beizutragen und da haben wir auch
versucht mit diesem live stream vielen
dank nochmal für die zuschriften und
auch für die fragen vielen dank an felix
zimmermann aus unserer redaktion recht
und justiz für den besuch bei uns danke
fürs reinschauen und dann hoffentlich
bis zum nächsten live stream dankeschön
schönen abend